[Musik]
willkommen bei bild 16 und 19 Jahre so
jung waren die Opfer des messertäters
von Brokstedt in Schleswig-Holstein
Opfer eines Staatenlosen Palästinensers
der gerade erst aus dem Knast gekommen
ist sind diese beiden Menschen
Opfer der deutschen Migrationspolitik
die richtigen Fragen jetzt bei Bild an
Wolfgang Kubicki Bundestagsvizepräsident
dieser kleine Ort 2000 Einwohner
Brokstedt sie kennen Schleswig-Holstein
sehr gut leben selber dort womit haben
sie Brot steht bisher verbunden
mit einem Ort bei dem man durchfährt
wenn man von China Hamburg fährt oder
zurückfährt den in der Regel hält der
Regionalzug in Frist und nicht im
Burgstädt aber ich glaube die Brust der
selbst wären lieber mit anderen Dingen
verbunden was ihren online geht als mit
Tötungsdelikten in der Bahn deswegen
frage ich habe jetzt wird dieser kleine
Ort wie gesagt 2000 Einwohner
wahrscheinlich für immer mit diesem
schrecklichen Messerangriff dieser Messe
Attacke verbunden sein was haben
Menschen die in Brokstedt leben oder
dort eben mit dem Regionalexpress fahren
vorbeifahren wie sie gerade sagen was
haben die zu tun mit einem Staatenlosen
palästinense nichts und für mich
verbindet sich auch weniger mit dem Ort
als mit dem Regionalzug denn den nutze
ich auch gelegentlich ähnlich wie meine
Frau von Hamburg nach Berlin oder von
Kiel nach Berlin und es ist schon
bedrückend wie nah eine solche Tat rückt
wenn man selbst diese regional Ziege
benutzen mit den täglich fährt und man
sieht nicht mehr sicher sein kann dass
ich sowas nicht wiederholt noch mal die
Frage sie haben schon gesagt nichts
damit zu tun aber die dort in dem Zug
ganz normale Pendler zwischen Kiel und
Hamburg anderthalb Stunden ungefähr und
zwei von denen 16 und 19 Jahre alt wenn
getötet durch einen Mann der 2014 als
Staatenloser Palästinenser gekommen ist
was haben die mit dem Typen zu tun
überhaupt nicht sie hätten auch mit
einem anderen Täter auch einen deutschen
Täter der psychisch krank ist das hatten
wir Anfang an auch nichts zu tun aber
diese Tat wie andere taten wir hatten
2020 über 20.000 Messerattacken davon
40% durch junge Männer mit
Migrationshintergrund müssen auch schon
zu der Frage führen was ist zwischen
2014 und 2016 falsch gelaufen als er
Millionen Menschen zu uns gekommen sind
bei denen wir wahrscheinlich nicht genau
darauf geschaut haben was es für
Menschen sind und ob wir nicht
vielleicht gut garantierten einige von
denen nicht in Deutschland zuzulassen
das vertiefen wir jetzt und genau
deswegen frage ich was haben die mit dem
Typen zu tun denn ganz einfach gedacht
liegt es ja auf der Hand wenn derjenige
nicht zwei 14 gekommen wäre wäre diese
Tat zumindest nicht passiert ja weiß es
doch schlicht gedacht der manche Täter
wenn die nicht geboren worden wären wäre
die Tat auch nicht passiert das ist
nicht eine Frage wo kommt der her
sondern wie ist der strukturiert und was
haben unsere Behörden bei Menschen die
nach Deutschland gekommen sind falsch
gemacht den eins ist klar auch in der
deutschen Gesellschaft gibt es 13%
Menschen die krimino gehen sind also
dazu neigen Straftaten zu begehen und
wenn über eine Million Menschen zu uns
kommen dann heißt es eben nur das
Übersetzen das auch 13% von den
kriminieren sind das bedeutet
Millionen Menschen 130.000 Menschen
zusätzlich bei denen er die Möglichkeit
an der Straftaten besteht und für einen
vor allen Dingen auch einige Menschen
mit posttraumatischen
Belastungsstörungen die hier nicht
behandelt werden können behandelt wurden
und jeder dass das tickende Zeitbomben
sind gleichwohl es darf sich nicht
wiederholen was 2015/2016 passiert ist
wir müssen bei jedem der zu uns kommt
genau darauf achten worum handelt es
sich ich suche gerade noch mal das
Vorstrafenregister raus denn das ist
lang und tatsächlich beeindruckend
Ibrahima seit 2014 eben in Deutschland
am 16
dezember 2021 beginnt eine gefährliche
Körperverletzung danach fällt da noch
zweimal auf wegen Diebstählen dann 8
Januar 2022 erneute Körperverletzung
wird damit aktenkundig 10 Tage später am
18 Januar 22 gibt's wieder Streit bei
einer Essensausgabe in einem ab
Obdachlosenheim der sticht er zum ersten
Mal zu mit einem Messer und 20 Januar 22
dann noch mal in Angriff mit dem Messer
diesmal schlägt er damit zu und
Klappmesser und dann geht er in U-Haft
wenig später kommt der raus
sechs Tage auf freiem Fuß und sticht
dann tödlich zu zweimal ja also kommt
aus der U-Haft weil die Uhr fasst dir
die strafhafte erreicht hatte die
ausgeurteilt worden ist dass es
Amtsgericht in Hamburg und es geht der
Grundsatz dass niemand länger in Urlaub
sitzen darf als er verurteilt worden ist
das Urteil war zwar noch nicht
rechtskräftig aber er hatte Berufung
eingelegt gegen sein Urteil ja also das
ist rechtsstaatlich nicht zu
veranstanden das Problem was wir haben
es ist ein Staatenloser Palästinenser
wir können auch nicht zurückführen weil
Palästina keinen Staat ist und manchmal
sind da muss man fast wegwerfen dann war
es das dann hat Deutschland momentan
keine Möglichkeiten der kontrollierten
Rückführung was notwendig wäre wir
müssen uns jetzt mit der Frage
beschäftigen es ist ja die Vergangenheit
die uns jetzt einholt wir haben jetzt
wieder mehrere hunderttausend Menschen
die zu uns kommen wir dürfen die Fehler
von 25 15 nicht wiederholen das bedeutet
wir müssen
die Integrationsmöglichkeiten unseres
Landes im Auge behalten ich bin ein
wirklicher Anhänger von Joachim Gauck
der mal gesagt hat unser Herz ist groß
aber unsere Möglichkeiten sind begrenzt
und dessen müssen wir uns bewusst sein
wir können nicht unendlich viele
Menschen bei uns aufnehmen die wir dann
auch nicht mehr betreuen und integrieren
können jetzt bleiben wir aber noch mal
das ist die große Frage dahinter bei den
konkreten Fall und auch vielleicht
versuchen wir diesen Fall aus Sicht der
Angehörigen zu betrachten
erstmal mitfühlen natürlich mit denen in
diesen Stunden und dann aber natürlich
Fragen stellen an die Behörden warum war
dieser Mann hier warum war dieser Mann
noch hier finden Sie eine Antwort
er war hier weil er dann nach
Deutschland geflohen ist 2014 er ist
noch hier weil wir ihn nicht abschieben
können weil wir keine Möglichkeit haben
ihn in ein anderes Land zu bringen das
ihn aufnimmt
und weil offensichtlich zwischen 2014
und 2015 und heute angesichts der
kriminellen Karriere dieses Mannes nicht
sorgsam darauf geachtet worden ist ihn
vielleicht eine genaueren Beobachtung
zuzuführen das ist auch ein Mengen
Problem wir haben nicht ausreichend
polizeiliche Kapazitäten aber ich teile
die Auffassung von von Achmed Masur der
gesagt hat wir müssen wenn Menschen zu
uns kommen ihnen relativ schnell
deutlich machen wie unsere Rechtssystem
funktioniert und
das geht immer nur dann wenn man das
auch vollzieht wir haben ja wir zeigen
uns wir haben Länder die glauben dass
Nachsicht die bessere Möglichkeit ist
mit Menschen die zu uns kommen umzugehen
ich glaube das mittlerweile nicht das
zeigen wir den Männern seit vielen
Jahren dass wir mit sehr viel Nachsicht
bei Körperverletzungen bei Diebstählen
die Konsequenzen dieser Nachricht ist
nicht dass es aufhört sondern das ist
intensiviert wird und das ist ein
Problem und ich glaube schon dass die
Gesellschaft so weit ist das nicht mehr
zu erkennen sondern das auch zu ändern
zu wollen was beispielsweise die
Reaktionen auf vom Polizeibeamten gerade
in Berlin an Silvester belegen nach all
dem was Sie gesagt haben ist nicht davon
auszugehen dass dieser Ibrahim a auch
nach dieser Tat abgeschoben wird der
wird hier bleiben
ja aber nach dieser Zeit wenn er hier
bleibt wird Interesse seines Lebens im
Gefängnis zu bringen und nicht und oder
in der psychiatischen Anstalt ich weiß
nicht aber nicht vielleicht tatsächlich
geistig verwirrt und gestört ist aber er
wird das kann man sicher sagen nicht nur
er als jemanden Migrationshintergrund
sondern auch jeder Deutsche Straftäter
dieser Art würde Interesse seines Lebens
im Gefängnis verbringen und nicht mehr
auf die Allgemeinheit losgelassen andere
Länder treffen Abkommen beispielsweise
Dänemark mit Ruanda und führt Straftäter
dorthin dann abschiebt sie ab wäre das
ein Weg für Deutschland solche Abkommen
zu schließen es ist immer gut Abkommen
zu schließen beispielsweise mit Marokko
oder Tunesien oder Libyen ähm selbst
wenn es teurer wäre es wäre sinnvoll
Staatsangehörige aus diesen Ländern
zurückzubringen wenn Sie bei uns
strafrechtlich geworden sind denn eins
muss man sagen die Europäische
Menschenrechtskonvention und auch unsere
international Vereinbarungen sehen zwar
ein recht aller vor die zu uns kommen
auf einer Asylverfahren oder bei
Flüchtlingen auf zu werden aber dieses
Recht erlischt auch nach der
Europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention
wenn diese Persönlichkeiten eine Gefahr
für die öffentliche Sicherheit und
Ordnung darstellen und bei Straftätern
dieser Kategorie mit
körperverletzungshandlungen und Todes
Handlungen ist das sicherlich der Fall
insofern müssen wir konsequenter sein
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob das
dänische Modell Bestand haben wird
innerhalb der Europäischen Union aber
sollte es bestand haben wäre das für
mich Orientierungspunkt das heißt sie
können sich vorstellen jemanden der in
dem Fall ja Staatenloser palästinser im
gar kein Staat hat in den er zurück
abgeschoben werden könnte dass man ein
Abkommen mit einem in diesem Fall von
Dänemark wäre das eine afrikanischer
Staat Ruanda ein Abkommen trifft und den
Straftäter dorthin abschiebt ja es kommt
nicht darauf an dass jemand eine
Staatsangehörigkeit sondern der Signatur
der Domizil starten muss auch bereit
sein aufzunehmen und das ist ja diese
Sache wir müssen auch entsprechend
Abkommen in Libyen Marokko Tunesien
den Libanon schließen damit die Staaten
bereit wären ihre Staatsbürger auch
selbst wieder aufzunehmen denn wenn die
auf dem Flughafen sagen der kann wieder
zurückfliegen dann müssen wir wieder mit
nach Hause nehmen also insofern wäre das
eine Möglichkeit wenn wir einen Staat
finden der sagt wir sind bereit die
entsprechende Persönlichkeiten
aufzunehmen und wir garantieren können
dass die einigermaßen menschenwürdig
dort auch leben können dann wünschen sie
dir nicht den Wege sie können jetzt
anfangen zu suchen nach diesen Staaten
sie stellen jetzt in der Bundesregierung
den sozusagen abschiebe-beauftragten mit
Joachim stammt der fängt jetzt in Kürze
mit seinem neuen Job an das heißt er
wird suchen nach diesen Staaten die
Frage müssen sie auch im Stamm stellen
aber ich kann nur feststellen als er in
Nordrhein-Westfalen dafür zuständig war
war es das Bundesland mit den meisten
Abschiebungen von auffällig gewordenen
Personen und insofern wenn ich da
optimistisch dass wenn einer ist
überhaupt auf die Reihe kriegt deswegen
haben wird zuletzt sind von 300.000
ausreisepflichtigen in Deutschland zwei
Prozent in einem halben Jahr abgeschoben
worden was wäre so eine Zielmarke für
ihn
die ziehenmarke muss dann das alle die
die kein Aufenthaltsrecht haben bei uns
auch das Land wieder verlassen müssen
und das zwangsweise auch durchgesetzt
werden kann das ist das Ziel und wissen
wir aus Erfahrung das war der eine 100%
Quote nicht erreichen würden aber es
wäre schon schön wenn wir mehr als die
Hälfte in absehbarer Zeit wieder aus dem
Land herausbringen können eine weil noch
einmal Menschen die bei uns sich an die
Rechtsordnung nicht halten wollen das
dezidiert auch immer gebracht haben
durch ihre Taten haben tatsächlich auch
kein Blei und vorbei Recht das sind wir
auch den anderen Menschen die aus
anderen Stellen zu uns kommen schuldig
damit nicht alle über einen Kamm
geschert werden und dann das Problem
entsteht dass Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund diskretiert wird
wir haben in diesen Tagen über einen
Fall berichtet von einem Afghanen auch
der war ja möglicherweise für die
Geschichte der vergangenen Jahre so
typisch ein Straftäter der in
Deutschland seine Straftat begangen hat
eine schwere Vergewaltigung er wurde
daraufhin bestraft er wurde daraufhin
auch abgeschoben nach Afghanistan
urplötzlich tauchte der wieder auf weil
er über die Schweiz nichts mit der
Straßenbahn einfach
rübergefahren ist wieder über die Grenze
nach Deutschland und dort durch einen
Zufall letztlich aufgegriffen wurde
durch baden-württembergische
Polizeibeamte jetzt sitzt da wieder im
Gefängnis aber es ist auch klar der wird
nie wieder abgeschoben weil wir im
Moment nach Afghanistan nicht abschieben
ein Mann der eigentlich dort sein müsste
der abgeschoben werden durfte den dürfen
wir jetzt nicht zurückschieben das ist
doch irre gut auch da muss man sagen wir
haben ihn abgeschoben wir in der
Situation als die Taliban noch nicht die
Regierungsverantwortung übernommen haben
aber er wäre sowieso aber auch da ja
aber noch einmal jetzt gibt der gibt's
neue Verhältnisse aber auch da wäre sie
denkbar da wir auch mit der
afghanischen Führung darüber verhandeln
wie mit den ortskräften vor Ort noch
umgegangen wird dass man vielleicht
dafür Sorge tragen kann dass eine
Rückführung möglich wird wenn keine
Todesstrafe und Menschen über die
Bedingungen Afghanistan jeweils für
diese Person dann vorherrschen also ich
werde etwas pragmatischer als wir es
gegenüber ändern wir stoßen definitiv
unsere Leistungsgrenzen innerhalb
unserer Gesellschaft wir können die
Vielzahl von Menschen die zu uns kommen
auch schon gegengewärtig auch aktuell
jetzt zu uns kommen nicht mehr sinnvoll
integrieren wird das Gewaltproblem dass
wir aktuell haben zum Beispiel mit Blick
auf messertaten zum Beispiel mit Blick
auf schwere Straftaten
Körperverletzungen Vergewaltigung von
Frauen dass wir dieses Gewaltproblem an
unseren Grenzen lösen
es wäre sehr schön wenn wir das könnten
wir können es aber nicht wie gesagt weil
jeder der europäischen Boden betritt ein
Anspruch darauf hat dass er einem
rechtschreiblich Verfahren unterworfen
wird und dann eine bestimmte Zeit auch
hier ist wir müssten konsequenterweise
diejenigen die keinen Bleiberecht haben
weil wieder sie wieder Kriegsflüchtlinge
sind noch einer Syrien gegeben ist
konsequent rückgefühlt werden denn
ansonsten wird das ganze System der
Kontrolle sich ins wird absolet und sich
ins Gegenteil Verkehr das Gespräch mit
ihnen ist fast der illusionieren der sie
sagen jetzt seit einer Viertelstunde was
wir leider alles nicht können können wir
nur Obergrenze schaffen eine neue
Obergrenze die funktioniert wir haben so
viel illegale Einwanderung wie seit
sechs Jahren nicht in Deutschland das
könnten wir nur wenn wir das
schenke-system aufheben würden
eigentlich kann ja niemand nach den
Regeln die Europa haben Deutschland
erreichen außer
aus dem Flugzeug denn wir sind ja nur
von Ländern umgeben bei denen
Asylbewerber oder Flüchtlinge zuerst
ankommen und dort aufgenommen werden
müssen es sei denn wir haben ein
europäischen Partei Schlüssel an die
sich momentan auch leider keiner hält
das Problem könnten wir nur lösen wenn
wir das Schenken sie mal Aufführung
wieder Außengrenzen schaffen das heißt
die Grenzkontrollen wieder einführen
auch dann gibt es mit Sicherheit
Möglichkeiten Menschen zu uns zu
schleusen aber durch deutlich geringere
Zahlen entscheidend ist für mich das in
den letzten Jahren die Lernerfahrung
gemacht worden ist wer einmal
Deutschland erreicht kann immer hier
bleiben und das ist eine Missachtung
unserer Rechtsordnung wer seine
Identität nicht preisgeben will wer
seine Pässe wegwirft wäre seine Wagen
die verschleiert der hat sein
Bleiberecht im Prinzip damit schon
verwirkt und muss Konsequenzen sich ein
Stück weit in diesem Gespräch auch dem
hilflos hin
ja es gibt Dinge die kann ich
bedauerlicherweise nicht ändern genauso
wenig wie sie und die die Illusion wir
stellen jetzt den Grenzschutz wieder
flächendeckend auf also die bayerische
Grenze in Richtung Süden Richtung
Österreich Richtung Tschechien ist so
immens dass selbst unsere ganzen
Sicherheitskräfte wenn wir sie in einem
Meter Abstand hinstellen würden nicht
ausreichen würden um die Grenzen
entsprechend zu schützen also eine
hundertprozentige sicheren Garantie gibt
es nicht aber es gibt die Notwendigkeit
unsere Rechtsordnung zumindest
durchzusetzen und nicht nach sich zu
üben niemand ist damit geholfen wenn wir
glauben wenn Leute und Strafe nicht
werden müssen wir das damit
entschuldigen dass sie auch schlechten
Verhältnissen rauskommen das hilft nicht
weiter sondern ich teile noch einmal die
Auffassung von von Masur der gesagt hat
von Anfang an muss konsequent deutlich
gemacht werden wer diese Rechtsordnung
missachtet richtig volle Breitseite des
Rechtsstaat zu spüren
wir haben eine Reaktion von der
Innenministerin gelesen bei Twitter
unter dem Eindruck dieser schweren
Straftat von Brokstedt in
Schleswig-Holstein und dieser so aus ich
weiß nicht wie viel Empathie Herr
Kubicki sie daraus lesen es sind würde
ich sagen sehr floskelhafte Worte von
Betroffenheit einer Innenministerin ich
bedauerieren kann aber vielleicht sagen
Sie mir mal was da steht die Sätze die
Politiker in solchen Momenten sagen sie
zeigen sich betroffen und gehen dann zu
Tagesordnung über kann diese Tat von
Bruch stellt diesmal etwas mehr sein und
tatsächlich die Politik verändern
eine realistische Antwort ja mit nein es
wird weitergehen wir nach jedem Unfall
zeigen die Betroffen mal nach jeder Tat
und davon hatten wir reichlich in der
Vergangenheit zeigen die Betroffenheit
die spannende Frage sind wir was kann
man tun und zwar unter unserer
rechtsstaatlichen Ordnung wir können
Menschen die ausreisepflichtig sind
gelegentlich auch in Ausreise haften
nehmen wo wir dann ein riesen Streit
bekommen nicht nur in unserer Koalition
sondern insgesamt ist das menschliches
das zutrennen kann man Menschen
einsperren die Ausreisepflicht sind aber
nicht ausreisen wollen
ich glaube es an der Zeit wenn wir nicht
erleben wollen dass die nachnahmeeffekte
von solchen Taten zunehmen werden denn
man muss wissen Menschen die zu uns
kommen und ihre Hoffnung Erwartungen
erfüllt sehen und dann zu solchen Taten
neigen wenn die nicht ordentlich
sanktioniert werden finden sehr schnell
Nachnahme weil man dann bekannt wird
berühmt wird jedenfalls ein Teil sein
selbst das Gefühl vielleicht wieder
aufbauen können wir müssen konsequent
werden und dazu gehört noch einmal dass
wir versuchen möglichst zu verhindern
dass mehr als eine bestimmte Anzahl von
Personen pro Jahr zu uns kommt
durch Überzeugung notfalls auch im
Rahmen der europäischen Einigung
notfalls auch indem wir auch da gibt es
ja Vorschläge aus Skandinavien die ja
nicht die Länder sind ja nicht dafür
bekannt dass sie sehr abweisend waren
die sagen in verschiedenen Bereichen
müssen wir zusehen dass unmittelbar nach
der Grenze die Asylverfahren bereits
offensichtlich keine aus ihrer Erfolg
eine solche Verfahrens hat der kann
nicht weiter nach Europa durchgelassen
werden das bedeutet dann eben
Auffanglager
auffangeinrichtungen in Griechenland in
Italien in Spanien dann müssen wir den
Menschen dort vor Ort auch helfen weil
die ja dann besonders belastet sind aber
anders werden wir es nicht schaffen und
vielleicht auch mal wenn das dänische
Modell tatsächlich erfolgreich sein
sollte mit Staaten in anderen Ländern
von denen wir davon ausgehen können Sie
achten die Menschenrechte versuchen
Rückführungsabkommen zu schließen weil
ich glaube jemand der von Palästina nach
Deutschland will und in Ruanda landet
dann irgendwann nach Palästina
zurückkehren wird das ist der ganz
kleine Funken Hoffnung an einem Tag der
sonst ja sehr viel Wut und sehr viel
Verzweiflung sehr viel Hilflosigkeit
auch mit sich gebracht hat und sehr
ehrliches Gespräch darüber mit dem
Bundestag viel zu Präsidenten Wolfgang
Bild danke ihnen wir sind gleich zurück
nach einer ganz kurzen Pause
[Musik]
zurück bei Bild die richtigen Fragen für
Ihr Portemonnaie ja es geht jetzt auch
um ihr Geld um all das was teurer wird
und immer immer teurer zum Beispiel ja
das Bier
7,50 € für ein einziges kneipenbier auch
darüber spreche ich jetzt mit Julia
Klöckner der cdu-wirtschaftsexpertin und
mit Bettina Hagedorn der SPD
Bundestagsabgeordneten ihnen beiden
herzlich willkommen
aber trotzdem man muss nicht weinen
können gewesen sein um Wein zu trinken
um das kurz noch mal fest zu halten
schon bisschen länger her ich weiß auch
nicht was es gekostet habe die nächste
Frage
Dornen Kneipen Bier also ich trinke ja
auch weil obwohl nicht Weinkönigin
gewesen
haben und ich würde mir das auch schon
lange her im Grunde wurscht nein das ist
mir nicht im Grunde wurscht aber es ist
auch sehr unterschiedlich ob ich das mir
in Eutin bestellt oder in Timmendorfer
stimmt und trotzdem sind das ja Warnung
die vom Brauerbund in der Zeit kommen
die kneipenbier für 7,50 € oder lassen
wir 7 € sein
also erstmal muss man das machen ja die
Brauer nicht einfach weil sie Lust und
Spaß haben weil sie eine riesen Marge
haben wollen sondern den geht an die
Existenz die Leiden noch unter der
coronazeit das war Massivs als die
Gastronomie geschlossen hatte und jetzt
ist es so dass zum einen Kohlensäure
richtig gestiegen ist im Preis und zum
anderen im übrigen auch bei Flaschen
also alleine das Glas ist so enorm
gestiegen ja aber noch mal die Frage
7,50 € halten Sie das für ein
angemessenen Preise in dem wir alle
wissen angemessen ist noch mal deshalb
wenn ich jetzt sage Klöckner hältst
nicht für angemessen dann ruhige ich ja
die Brauer ich kann die Brauer nicht
drüben die müssen ja zumindest was
verdienen können also ich sag jetzt mal
kurzum die Inflation auch wenn der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister heute in der
Debatte sagte er hätte den Trend
gebrochen weniger Inflation heißt nicht
dass es billiger wird sondern es wird
nur langsamer teurer naja aber die Frage
ist schon noch deswegen Behar ich so auf
diesen 7,50€ noch mal Frau Hagedorn
können sich ihre Wähler im Schnitt
solches Bier leisten oder trinken die
dann keins mehr trinken die weniger also
ich glaube schon meine Wählerschaft ist
breit gefächert aber ganz allgemein
gesprochen muss ich sagen
es wird der es werden die Gaststätte
beim Umsatz wahrscheinlich merken weil
die allermeisten haben ja nicht endlos
viel Geld in der Tasche die trinken dann
sicherlich ein Bier weniger bei uns ist
natürlich die tourismusversicherung im
Sommer das alles entscheidende und um
ganz ehrlich zu sein ohne das Thema
wechseln zu wollen das was dort am
meisten kneift ist der Fachkräfte Mangel
im letzten Sommer wo die Restaurants an
der Küste alle voll waren und es ist ein
guten Absatz gab haben viele Restaurants
ein zwei Tage schließen müssen weil
nicht genug Personal zur Verfügung stand
jetzt können wir da so drüber
hinweggehen können sagen ja gut das Bier
und jetzt witziges Beispiel und so ne
ist es ja gar nicht die Deutschen werden
sich weniger Bier leisten können Bier
ist was so urdeutsches sie wollen wissen
was Politik tun muss sage ich Ihnen sehr
klar auch als Oppositionspolitikerin wir
brauchen einmal ein Sofortprogramm
Wirtschaft in diesem Land deshalb und
was auch die Arbeitnehmer und auch die
Konsumenten betrifft Nummer ein Beispiel
das Thema kalte Progression selbst wenn
es eine Gehaltserhöhung gibt für die
Arbeiten dann ist es so dass weniger
genau und im vergangenen Jahr wurde die
kalte Progression nicht ausgeglichen was
ich für ein Fehler halte und wir halten
für absolut notwendig dass die kalte
Progression jetzt vollständig ausgeht
machen sie mit Nein Stopp das ist falsch
das ist keine Steuersenkung es ist kein
Geschenk des Staates an den Bürger
sondern der Staat nimmt gerade viel mehr
Geld ein als er dürfte und da müssen wir
schon in Ordnung bleiben
Sie damit bei der kalten Progression aus
ich endlich wie Frau Klöckner sagt geh
davon aus der Haushalt 23 ist ja
verabschiedet und da ist das nicht drin
enthalten das sind viele andere
Hilfsmaßnahmen enthalten die sehr viel
Geld kosten und es ist natürlich so dass
wir die Schuldenbremse einhalten wollen
mit dieser Regierung und darum wird die
Maßnahme aus meiner Sicht nicht zu
finanzieren seine dieser in diesem
Moment aber warten wir mal ab ob Herr
Lindner dazu Vorschläge z.B auf dem
Tisch liegt aber die müssten dann ja
auch gegen finanziert sein im Haushalt
24 ja aber sehr klar sagen das meinte
man muss ja klar sagen geld ist genug da
wir haben so hohe Steuereinnahmen das
ist Rekord jetzt die Frage was machen
wir damit also wir hatten noch nie so
viel Personal auf wuchs wie wir es jetzt
in der dieser Bundesregierung haben und
ich finde es ungerecht am kleinen am
großen Mann und Frau wenn jemand sich
wirklich eine Gehaltserhöhung verdient
hat und im übrigen der Arbeitgeber ja
mehr zahlt aber bei dem Arbeitnehmer das
mehr gar nicht so ankommt und auf der
anderen Seite
der Starter durch Milliarden einnimmt
ohne dass es eigentlich als also so auch
hinterlegt ist das ist ja eine der
Krisengewinner ist der Staat und das ist
nicht in Ordnung vielleicht hängt es
auch damit zusammen dass der
Wirtschaftsminister selber gar nicht das
Empfinden hat dass das jetzt wahnsinnig
schlimm ist der die Inflation er sagt na
das Wirtschaftswachstum das fährt ja
langsam wieder hoch langsam
fehlt ihm das Gespür an der Stelle das
weiß ich nicht ob ihnen das Gespür für
das sollte man Politikern auch nicht
immer pauschal unterstellen aber ich bin
auch muss ich sagen als diesen diesen
Jahreswirtschaftsbericht gelesen habe
über den wir heute ja debattiert haben
in deutschen Bundestag weil ich auch
erstaunt dass im eigenen
Wirtschaftsbericht da habe ich eine
Prognose hat die die Fachexperten nicht
teilen im übrigen wissen wir dass aus
der corona-zeit noch
auftragsrückstand da war der jetzt
abgebaut wird ich sehe unsere Wirtschaft
Null über den Berg sie hat
wirklich mit mit
Preis Schocks zu kämpfen mit
Lieferketten mit mit Fachkräften die
fehlen zu kämpfen mit pleitewellen zu
kämpfen schauen Sie doch mal in die
Region ich kann sagen für meine Region
auch welche Bäckereien Metzgereien
klassische uralte Handwerksbetriebe
schließen mussten die haben vieles
überlebt aber das haben sie jetzt gerade
nicht überlegt sind das die Opfer der
Regierung auch auch wieder zu pauschal
ich weiß es ist eine schnelle hellblau
aber ich würde
Opfer es ist immer man es gibt
maßnahmenpolitische Art die hätten
geholfen dass sie jetzt nicht schließen
müssen sage ich sehr klar denn viele der
Hilfsmaßnahmen
wir hätten einen ganz klares Zeichen
gesetzt bei der geburtsseite Stichwort
Energie dass wir die Kernkraftwerke eben
nicht im April abschalten zweiter Punkt
ist
wenn wir uns das noch mal anschauen das
Thema kalte Progression das Thema
Bürokratie Zettelwirtschaft in dieser
Zeit wir hätten jetzt hätten wir als
Union ein Sofortprogramm Wirtschaft
gemacht und hätten auch Dinge die wir
vorher beschlossen haben ist ja nicht so
dass wir heilig sind aber dann auch
korrigiert warum haben sie eine anderen
Weg gewählt und haben wie Frau Klöckner
jetzt gerade unterstellt die Bäcker und
die Metzger pleite gehen lassen naja
also so ist es ja nun nicht und im
übrigen bin ich seit 20 Jahren im
Bundestag und im Haushaltsausschuss und
kann beurteilen dass wir noch 20 Jahre
dabei sehen deswegen kennen wir uns ja
auf jeden Fall
Verantwortung wir sind gemeinsame
Regierungsarbeit so aber es ich habe
noch kein Jahr erlebt in dem die
Regierung so viel anders gemacht hat als
sie sich das ursprünglich mal
vorgenommen hatte das muss man ja
fairerweise sagen und alles wurde im
Kopf auf den Kopf gestellt durch den 24
februar und durch den Krieg und wir
kamen aus einer Zeit die wir noch
gemeinsam in der Regierung gehabt haben
mit der corona-pandemie die auch länger
gedauert hat und schwieriger zu
bewältigen
auch und sagt ganz klar sie mehr
Maßnahmen eingebracht
und Metzger und Bäcker zu retten sie
haben auch die Antwort erstmal gelacht
und haben gesagt naja also nein putin
ist Schuld nein ich habe nicht gesagt
putin ist Schuld ich durfte ja nicht
ausreden ich wollte darauf hinweisen
dass wir zwei corona-jahre hinter uns
gemeinsam in der großen Koalition
gebracht haben da haben wir ja auch
Milliarden schwere Hilfspakete zurecht
und richtigerweise geschnürt um die
Wirtschaft zu unterstützen aber
selbstverständlich wäre es nicht nur der
Wirtschaft lieber sondern uns wäre es
auch lieber gewesen wir hätten Sie nicht
so stützen müssen weil sie es einfach
alleine geschafft hätte aber die
Umstände mit der corona-pandemie waren
so und dann hatten wir die Hoffnung wow
jetzt haben wir die lassen wir die
allmählich hinter uns und dann kam der
Krieg und was dann passiert ist und ja
nicht nur in Deutschland sondern
weltweit also dass die Kosten bei dem
Bier brauen das hängt ja auch mit
liefern zusammen und so weiter also das
sind ja Sachen die jetzt erst einmal
nicht sofort politisch ganz schnell zu
beeinflussen sind und da hat diese
Regierung sehr viel gemacht und
geleistet
wir sehen den Wirtschaftsminister sie
haben das gerade angesprochen wir sehen
den Wirtschaftsminister der zeigt die
Kurven ins Fernsehen und wirkt dabei
eigentlich ganz zufrieden sie wirken
ganz genauso und dabei zahlen wir halt
bald 7,50 € für ein Bier Einkaufen
7,50 € gibt andere Bereiche und da sagen
Familie die sagen der redet hier als vom
Bier können wir machen aber es gibt auch
Brot es gibt auch mehr Milch da bin ich
froh dass die Landwirte jetzt mal ein
bisschen mehr auch in der Tasche haben
auch das müssen wir jetzt mal sagen und
es geht das was man jeden Tag auch
braucht und und da gehört aber auch
Sommer Lebensqualität auch das dazu was
sie erwähnt Stichwort Bier am Ende geht
es darum nicht jetzt einer Regierung
kann man ja keinen Vorwurf machen das
ist Krieg gibt aber es geht darum ob ich
handle in dieser Zeit ein Beispiel jetzt
in der corona-krise da haben wir auch
Milliarden die Hand genommen und wir
haben auch die fünf mal gerade sein
lassen man kann entweder zaubern und
dann ein
Programm auflegen wie Herr Habeck
gemacht hat verschiedene die Gas
chaosumlage das war naja was für die
Tonne dann hatten wir ein Beispiel wie
wir energieintensive Unternehmen Stützen
es hat aber nicht gepasst für den Bäcker
und für den Metzger und für diese
Unternehmen weil diese Förderprogramme
sind gar nicht abgerufen worden und da
sage ich das ist handwerklich etwas was
nicht in Ordnung ist und das ist schon
Regierungs gemacht aktuell und wenn ich
dann noch mal mehr anschaue wie die
Energiekosten gehe ich in die USA ich
schau mal an weil ich komme aus aus
Rheinland-Pfalz biontech entscheidet
sich jetzt fürs außer also außer
europäisches Ausland auch Großbritannien
dort jetzt mehr zu investieren BASF
Bayern sie sagen sehr klar aufgrund der
hohen Energiekosten in Deutschland
suchen wir uns Alternativen und da
müssen die Alarmglocken angehen und da
kann man nicht sagen wir wir wir
schalten jetzt die Kernkraft ab aber
importieren Sie von woanders her da
sprechen wir darüber aber das Abschalten
der Kernkraft noch ein paar Fragen würde
ich gerne was sagen würde machen wir
sofort einmal der konkreteste Punkt
waren die Kernkraftwerke mit
abschaltensprogramme in den auch in
diesem Jahr analog übrigens in durchaus
ähnlich wie in der corona-pandemie mit
dieser Regierung gestrickt haben und
dabei haben wir sehr wohl hier
Unternehmen gesteckt aber wir haben
vorhin gekauf Kraft gestärkt der Leute
die eben nicht so viel Geld im
Portemonnaie haben weil das Geld dann
nämlich tatsächlich direkt ausgegeben
wird und das ist wichtig wir haben auch
z.B weil sie Miete angesprochen haben
wir haben nicht nur die
wohngeld-empfänger mit einer ein Mal
Zahlung entlassen sondern wir haben dort
extrem lange die Anträge sind gegangen
zum Beispiel bei ihnen in
Schleswig-Holstein es gibt überall Chaos
auf dem enter die Wohngeld Empfänger die
sind schon im März 2022 mit dem ersten
entlassungspaket mit einer pauschalen
Entlastung von 200 € bei einzelnen
Person ist das ist richtig aber das
ja kein Geld verloren weil dieses Jahr
rückwirksam 4 Monate später das macht in
einem sehr eng gestrickten Haushalt
verdammt viel aus vier Monate später ist
ich glaube das ist auch von Kommune zu
kommunizieren
manchmal sechs Monate manchmal geht es
auch schneller in jedem Fall sieht bei
ihnen ist das Glas jetzt immer halb leer
bei mir ist es eher halb voll warum weil
es ja darum geht zu sagen was hat diese
Regierung eigentlich gemacht damit es
schnell geht und wenn man schnell sein
will dann muss man auch mal Dinge
pauschal machen wir haben Familien mit
Kindern analog also das Kindergeld wurde
zweimal mit einer Einmalzahlung stimmt
alles die Wohngeld Empfänger wurden
entlassen die Rentnerin und Rentiere
damit in den Taschen der Menschen für
die tatsächlich spürbar war und das
bestimmte Dinge im Saarland Einkaufen
Energiepreise zu hoch das war ja ein
Stichwort auch von Frau wir wandern ab
die Bayern text-chefs die sagen das
war's für uns hier in Deutschland ist es
nicht unfass sehr peinlich für uns an
ein bisschen müssen wir jetzt die
Kirschen Dorf lassen sie gehen ja nicht
ganz aus Deutschland weg zu sagen das
war's für uns in Deutschland stimmt ja
nicht aber was stimmt und das muss man
sich genau anschauen auch mal die
Pressemitteilung von Bayer und Heck das
ist eine Klatsche für Deutschland sehr
klar auch für neue Entscheidungen die
Bürokratie für die Regierung also ich
könnte ihn da auch einiges über die
Landesregierung Rheinland-Pfalz sagen es
hat auch etwas dazu damit zu tun mit mit
Bürokratie mit
Dokumentationspflichten
genehmigungsdauern
ja sind wir definitiv und wenn ich mir
jetzt enorm Kontrollrat anschaue der war
ja früher im Kanzleramt hat eine ganz
prominente Stellung der wurde jetzt
degradiert und in ein Ministerium ins
Justizministerium verbannt der Normen
Kontrolle hat gesagt sehr klar allein
schon in dieser Regierungszeit
63% mehr Bürokratie Kosten das heißt
stattdessen Ingenieur oder ein
Handwerker einzustellen wenn Buchhalter
gesucht um die Dokumentation für Staat
zu fertigen in der jetzigen Zeit ist es
ein No-Go das ist die
deutschland-geschwindigkeit die ihr
Bundeskanzler angesprochen hat das
umständliche das Zögern des zaunen
und bei den Fakten ist es ja so und das
wird ja immer gerne besprochen wenn es
um die lng-terminals geht Deutschland
kann es ja auch unbürokratisch wenn es
mehrheitlich gewollt ist und dafür haben
wir ja Beispiele geliefert und unserer
gemeinsamen Regierungszeit und das ist
jetzt nicht die Schuld von Julia
klöckler aber da will sich eine Menge
Beispiel auch z.B im Verkehrsbereich und
Dinge 100 Jahre dauern das hängt daran
zusammen dass wir in der Tat in diesem
Bereich zu viel Bürokratie aufgebaut
haben und darum geht es ja auch einen
planungsbeschleunigung und das hat die
Regierung auf ihrer To Do-Liste für
dieses Jahr aber dann kann man auch
nicht alles beschleunigen sondern man
muss priorisieren und sich fokussieren
auf die Dinge die volkswirtschaftlich
also im Verkehrsbereich z.B und dann
geht's nicht nur am
straßenwege die volkswirtschaftlich
wichtig sind aber die auch wichtig sind
um die Klimaschutzziele zu sprechen weil
es war unsere Regierung
gemeinsam gemacht hat die sie über so
viele Jahrzehnte im Bundestag ja selber
angeschaltet haben sondern ich
beschreibe diese Regierung die
To-Do-Liste die so lange Jahrzehnte
schon auch ihre To-Do-Liste war wie auch
die Grundsteuer sie waren die
Finanzministerium haben das mit auf den
Weg gebracht Bürokratiemonster unter dem
gerade Millionen Deutsche ein Urteil die
einfach nicht mehr mitmachen
das Thema Energie
effizienzgesetz liegt vor klingt Bremer
aber es wird ein
Bürokratiemonster sein da fallen sie aus
dem schulungs mal kurz zu sagen und wenn
das eine Ministerium das eine sagt das
andere jenes sagt oder macht dann wird
das am Ende für die Betriebe einfach nur
heißen Addition von Dokumentation von
kostenkosten und der normale Bürger Zahl
ist und das bringt finde ich nichts wenn
ich erstes Geld einsammele bei bei
Unternehmen oder auch bei den Produkten
und nachher ist den Leuten dann wieder
verteile also verschlanken zeitenwände
muss dann auch wirklich ankommen wir
bleiben noch mal bei den Energiekosten
Frau Hagedorn jetzt sitzt die Regierung
schon symbolhaft am Schalter sozusagen
es ist dann im Frühjahr oder Ende des
Winters ist tatsächlich Schluss mit der
Kernkraft in Deutschland werden sie das
wirklich tun werden Sie abschalten ja
was passiert an dem Tag an dem der
Schalter umgelegt ist
nicht
also sie glauben doch nicht dass diese
Regierung einfach so
naiv da reintaumelt doch nee das glaube
ich nicht was passiert an diesem Tag an
dem wir abgeschaltet haben wird es in
den Folgewochen stummknappheit geben und
werden die Strompreise stabil bleiben na
ob die Strompreise stabil bleibt das
können wir sowieso alle nicht sagen
wirklich in Wahrheit ist es doch so dass
wir auch vor dem Hintergrund der
Klimaschutzziele die wir gemeinsam
erreichen wollen und müssen das haben da
haben wir angesetzt so gemacht deshalb
dass die beiden dass die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie dass sie
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass die Strompreise
perspektivisch nachhaltig steigen werden
die Energiekosten überhaupt das ist sehr
wahrscheinlich und in dieser Situation
in der wir jetzt sind hat die Regierung
aber wegen der explosionsartigen
Energiekosten die von Putins Krieg
verursacht worden sind und weil wir
unsere Abhängigkeit von russischen
Erdgas abschalten mussten sozusagen und
weil haarspeicherlehrer nicht erfüllen
mussten aus diesen Gründen hat die
Regierung jetzt ihr zielgerichtet die
Menschen die Menschen aber unterstützt
das zu stemmen und das spielt natürlich
die die spielt natürlich die Bremse eine
total relevante Rolle
Markt und drücken auf den Schalter und
der Schalter bedeutet noch mal für die
Deutschen die Preise gehen weiter rauf
nein wir kommen also ich meine da können
wir darüber reden wenn es soweit ist ich
würde sagen das werde ich die Ursache
sein wir haben heute im Plenum ich war
ja auch bei der jahreswirtschaftsdebatte
dabei durchaus darüber gesprochen
dass wir ja zum Beispiel im letzten Jahr
über Monate Frankreich unterstützt haben
weil die so viele Kernkraftwerke vom
Netz nehmen mussten maßgeblich wegen des
niedrig Wassers ich sehe das aber an und
sie sind jetzt zum größten Teil wieder
am Netz ja und damit kann sich
Frankreich glücklicherweise
selbstverständlich
so ein Quatsch wir haben die Franzosen
unter selbst in diesem schwierigen Jahr
weil sie in der Klemme waren wegen ihrer
Kernkraftwerke reden müssen und jetzt
auch nicht und jetzt jetzt werden wir
die planmäßig die drei Atomkraftwerke
noch vom Netz nehmen das ist beschlossen
und es wird kein Chaos ausbrechen das
ist meine Prognose und wenn sie sagen
sie haben eine andere dann können wir
uns ja wieder treffen wenn es soweit ich
frage fragen
weil wir ja auch unterschiedlich
Sichtweisen herausarbeiten können ich
glaube schon dass etwas passiert bzw es
könnte was anderes passieren wenn man
nicht auf den Knopf drücken würde rein
volkswirtschaftlich gesehen wenn ich ein
Angebot verknappe und wir verknappen das
Angebot indem wir kein Kraftwerke vom
Netz nehmen ist eine schon mal klar die
Preise werden dadurch nicht senken
hätten wir eine Angebots Erweiterung und
ich meine wir beziehen ja Kernkraft im
übrigen stützen wir als Stadt Juniper
und uniper baut ins Skandinavien neue
Kernkraftwerke auch das müssen
neue atomker und genau das Netzagentur
der Präsident ist auch happy über jedes
Kernkraftwerk im Ausland das hat schon
was also ich finde das wasch mich aber
mach mir den Pelz nicht nass also
schauen wir uns mal an wir wollen Gas
Verpressen in Norwegen finden wir super
wir erholen LNG Gas aus aus den USA und
wir nehmen Kernkraft aus Frankreich aber
in Deutschland wollen wir das alles
nicht unsere Nachbarn sagen könnt ihr ja
machen aber das bezahlt ihr uns dann
richtig Deutschland ohne französischen
Atomstrom auskommen
also jetzt will ich erstmal was sagen
das was will
die Situation
geschrieben hat das ist das Ergebnis
einer gemeinsamen Politik der letzten
Jahre immer zurück nein aber das ist
aber auch wichtig Frage wir reden ja
über den volkswirtschaftlich relevanten
Beitrag von Energie und wenn wir diese
Abhängigkeit vom russischen Gast nicht
gehabt hätte sein gemeinsamer Fehler
genau und der über der repariert sich
nicht überladen dran daran ist aber
mittlerweile auch im Grunde genommen
aus Frankreich kann Deutschland ohne
französischen Atom das kann ich nicht
beurteilen müssen immer das nächste mal
Herr Müller einladen also Klaus Müller
meine ich denen ja ja
die Antwort ich bin ehrlicher
auch als Vorkämpfer gegen den deutschen
Atomstrom hervorgetan haben
also da war ich weiß nicht 25 zu Hause
geht aber geht aber auch mit
französischen Atomstrom und ihre
Waschmaschine zu Hause ökolog
isch in den 90er Jahren damals war ich
noch Bürgermeisterin und
Kommunalpolitikerin gewusst dass in den
90er Jahren alles bekannt ist das global
denken lokal handeln wir müssen
Ressourcen sparen und das ist richtig
und wenn wir es in den letzten 25 Jahren
konsequente in Deutschland getan hätten
dann würden wir nicht in der Misere
sitzen in der wir jetzt sind ja jetzt
müssen wir aber auch mal acht geben
Leute wir müssen mal von der Industrie
sprechen es gibt
Industriezweige Industriezweige die
können nicht auf die Volatilität
der erneuerbaren Energien die wir nach
wie vor noch haben aufgrund mangeler
Speicherfähigkeit etc können die nicht
verzichten das sind Arbeitsblätter von
Menschen die das kaufen wollen meine
Frage die eigentlich relativ einfach ist
können Deutschland ohne französische
attrakt in der jetzigen Zeit glaube ich
nicht zumindest nicht in den Phasen wo
die Sonne nicht scheint oder nicht
genügend scheint und wo wir nicht
genügend Winter haben und vor allen
Dingen ein hoch an Abnahme Bedarf an
Energie haben und es geht ja darum wir
Bürger machen das häufig ja gar nicht
wie ausgeglichen wird und natürlich
brauchen wir ein Stück Sicherheit und
jüngst gab es in Baden-Württemberg eine
Warnung auf die Handys diejenigen die
sich das runtergeladen hatten man möge
jetzt Strom sparen weil es knapp wird
dass wir Strom sparen müssen kein Thema
aber dennoch wir wir verstromen wir wir
verstromen noch Gas im übrigen Gas wo
wir versuchen echt zu minimieren den
Verbrauch und wir könnten und wir fahren
Kohlekraftwerke wieder hoch die
Klimaziele werden massiv gerissen und da
ist Deutschland wirklich kein
Musterschüler ich meine und deshalb sage
ich schon es wird immer Ziel Konflikte
geben aber da muss man sich ehrlich
machen und zwar jetzigen Zeit die
Kernkraftwerke abzuschalten halte ich
für fatal und es geht nicht darum dass
man leichtsinnig dahin geht ich habe
damals dafür gestimmt dass wir
aussteigen aus der Kernkraft aber wenn
es zeitenwender heißt dann heißt es auch
neu bewerten mit neuen Kriterien
das schwer in dieser Krise umzudenken
nein überhaupt nicht ich glaube das hat
die Regierung im letzten Jahr ja auch
bewiesen aber die Kernkraft bringt uns
ja keinen Schritt voran außer dass sie
eine sehr starke Lobby hat wie man ja
auch in der öffentlichen in der
veröffentlichen Meinung erkennen kann
aber wir haben ein
atomstarken sofort nur sie sie sagen
immer das hat eine starke Lobby sie
gehören doch im Grunde mit zu der
Atomkraft glaube ich weil sie fleißig
alle deutschen Atomkraft aus Frankreich
nutzen diese gern für unseren Preis und
unsere Versorgung also es war die rot
grüne Bundesregierung die vertraglich
den Ausstieg aus der Atomkraft
vereinbart hat und die Deutschland aus
der deutschen und den Einstieg in die
französische Atomkraft also Quatsch es
wurde damals in diesem Vertrag
vereinbart und das trägt ja die
Unterschrift braucht derjenigen die
damals für diese
Energieunternehmen die Verantwortung
getragen haben dass sie freiwillig
verabredet innerhalb von 20 Jahren
aussteigen dieser Vertrag wurde
gekündigt von der CDU fdp-regierung ein
halbes Jahr bevor Fukushima ausbrach und
das war der Grund dafür warum der nach
Fukushima als dann dieselbe Regierung
gesagt hat wir steigen jetzt doch aber
aus
milliardenschwere Ansprüche auf Regress
aus Steuermitteln hat nicht ich glaube
sieben Milliarden ich weiß ja gar nicht
zurückblick hilft weil das haben wir
alle auf Kasten das ist sonst hilft das
heißt dass unsere Wirtschaft und unsere
Energiewirtschaft natürlich sich
langfristig darauf einstellen konnte und
auch in weiten Teilen eingestellt hat
dass dies der Weg ist der in Deutschland
gegangen wird so ich hätte mir natürlich
gewünscht dass die erneuerbaren Energien
in den Jahren wo wir gemeinsam regiert
haben ein bisschen stärker passiert
weil es bestimmten Industriezweigen
nicht gelungen ist sie haben ja eine
Vorwarnung bekommen der Vertrag war ja
gemacht
Industrie nicht gelungen ist die
Energiewende rechtzeitig anzuschieben
wird jetzt die alleinerziehende Mutter
bestraft mit den steigenden Preisen weil
sie weiter
weiter unbedingt auf diesen Knopf
drücken es geht darum doch dass das
worum es jetzt der Streit eigentlich
geht ist dass die Atomkraftwerke Länge
am Netz bleiben das hat diese Regierung
ja entschieden 3 Monate länger aber dass
sie darüber wenn Sie darüber hinaus
länger am Netz bleiben dann müssen neue
Brennelemente
ja man hätte wenn man es gewollt hätte
die Frage ist ja wann hätten dann wann
hätte dann wirklich dieser Strom vor
allen Dingen ja auch mit all sein
negativen Konsequenzen es hat ja einen
Grund gegeben warum der Ausstieg aus der
Atomkraft beschlossen worden ist ja es
ist nämlich die teuerste Energie weil ja
ja Jahrzehnte lang all die lassen nur
negativ Auswirkungen vom getragen worden
sind abzuschalten wenn das Atomkraft
steht da bin ich einfach auch aber wir
sind ja dazu da dass wir hier
verschiedene Auffassungen haben genau
und die würde ich gerne auch jetzt
äußern das sei die teuerste Energie noch
teurer ist es genau dieser Energie die
man ablehnt woanders her zu importieren
ich finde das doppelmoralisch und
deshalb muss man sehr klar sein man kann
nicht von unseren europäischen Partnern
verlangen dass sie alle möglichen
Energiequellen nutzen und die Energie
zur Verfügung stellen was wir hier nicht
machen wollen und es ist ja nicht nur
die Kernkraft es hat was mit mit CO2
Verpressung zu tun es hat was mit
Gasgewinnung zu das hat was damit zu tun
dass wir auch Ressourcen in Deutschland
auch Bergen ist auch diese Debatte
müsste verantwortungsvoll von der
jetzigen Regierung geführt werden und
die Frage noch einmal der erneuerbaren
Energien ich ich kenne das aber das
immer heißt als er hätte Deutschland als
wenn wir die allerletzten bei den
erneuerbaren Energien die Fakten sind ja
ganz andere wir haben zum einen haben
wir die CO2 Reduktion mit etwas 40
Prozent geschafft von 25 bis 2020 wenn
wir uns anschauen der Anteil der
erneuerbaren Energien an unserem
Stromverbrauch sind wir auf 45 Prozent
hochgegangen das kann immer mehr sein
keine Frage aber am Ende spielt auch
Physik eine Rolle das eine ist ein
Wunsch was man gerne hätte aber wir
können die Physik nicht
auseinandersetzen
aufgeblättert der vergangenen zehn Jahre
ungefähr da ist die CDU ja auch
ungeeignet mal so mal so wenn eine
Wahlkampf Anstand dann raus aus der
Atomkraft danach irgendwann wieder rein
wie ist eigentlich jetzt aktuell die
Haltung von cdu/csu zu Atomkraft ganz
klar wir sind für eine Verlängerung der
Nutzung der Kernkraft es geht nicht um
den Ausstieg aus dem Ausstieg sondern
das was wir verantwortungsvoll jetzt
nutzen können deshalb halten wir es für
falsch das verpasst worden ist
kommt drauf an welche Atomkraftwerke
noch mal dass sie spielen sicherlich
darauf an was wir als Papier
verabschiedet haben gerade in Weimar und
wir sind wenn wir uns die Forschung
anschauen es geht eigentlich darum die
nächste Generation der Energienutzung
was die Forschung bei CAN Fusion und
Kernspaltung anbelangt ich bin keine
Forscherin aber zu sagen wir forschen da
nicht mehr dran um zum Beispiel die
negativen Implikationen irgendwann in
den Griff zu bekommen der hielt ich für
falsch dann sind wir auf dem
abstellkreis und deshalb
realistischerweise sagen wir sehr klar
diese Kernkraftwerke die sicher sind die
jetzt noch am Netz sind die müssen
länger genutzt werden können Sie sich
noch mal zurückkehren zu der
Alleinerziehenden Mama zum Beispiel
Kontakt ja dann wissen sie auch dass die
Strompreise vor allen Dingen dieser
Haushalte so extrem belasten können sie
sich in ihrer Argumentation dann in den
Spiegel schauen und sagen wir steigen
was der Atomkraft aus dafür nehmen wir
in Kauf dass der Preis zumindest
vorübergehend steigt und kaufen auf der
anderen Seite den französischen
Atomstrom wieder ein wie begründen sie
das gegenüber der beispielsweise
Alleinerziehenden Mama weil eine
alleinerziehende Mutter laut armuts und
reichtumsbericht wirklich zu der
Zielgruppe in Deutschland gehört die
wirklich am stärksten von Armut
betroffen ist und darum müssen genau
diese Bevölkerungsgruppen gezielt
unterstützt werden vom Staat und was
jetzt die Energiepreise anbelangt möchte
ich einmal kurz widersprechen dürfen
weil Julia Klöckner gerade eben gesagt
hat wir würden uns als deutsche darauf
verlassen dass wir auch in Zukunft
französischen Strom beziehen ich habe
wir haben einen europäischen Strommarkt
und ich habe vorhin darauf hingewiesen
dass wir die Franzosen im letzten Jahr
massiv unterstützt haben
aber das war eine lange Phase und das
hing nicht nur mit der Wartung der
gleichzeitigen Wartung von der Hälfte
der Atomkraftwerke zusammen sondern das
hing vor allen Dingen mit Sachen
zusammen wie z.B die sinkenden Pegel in
den Flüssen dass das Kühlwasser nicht
ausgereicht hat und diese Dinge und da
sind natürlich Elemente die auch in
Zukunft massiv denken wir an die
Pegelstände das reins im letzten Sommer
gibt mit denen wir massiv konfrontiert
sein werden und darum wenn wir Energie
Sicherheit in der Zukunft neu denken
wollen das war ja ihre Aufforderung von
da stimme ich Ihnen ja zu aber dann ist
das Setzen auf der Atomkraft
ausgerechnet das falsche Pferd das meine
Meinung und da sind wir eben
am Ende ist es ja Holzweg das ist das
sind Nationen das sind nationale
Entscheidung gesagt doch nicht auf dem
Flohmarkt weil wir ja deren Strom
einkaufen
erst wieder anmachen wenn der Franzose
der Natur
wie sie ihre Energie
sichern wollen
es gibt ein Strom macht ein
international
ob das aber sie wollen dass die
Atomkraft eine gute
Alternative mit dem moralischen Argument
wir sind bald atomstromfrei und kaufen
auf der anderen Seite
franzosen-orturmstrom rein wieder machen
sich damit das Licht an und sagen zu
Hause aber wir sind sauber totaler
Quatsch wir streben eine viel höhere
Quote noch an erneuerbaren Energien an
und wir haben aber einen europäischen
stromarkt und mal fehlt ihm ein Strom
und mal fehlte an und in Europa ist es
so geregelt dass wir das unter dass wir
uns dann untereinander aushelfen das ist
doch eine vernünftige Energiepreise
gestritten auch über den Atomstrom die
Kernkraft es gibt einen Wirtschaftszweig
der im Moment richtig gut läuft ich kann
mal einmal die Kurve hier in die Kamera
zeigen ja das ist die aktuelle
vielleicht geht's noch ein bisschen
näher ran die aktuelle
aktienkurve von Rheinmetall
läuft so gut
nein ich kaufe keine Aktie jetzt von
Rheinmetall aber ich kann rein Metall
nicht vorwerfen dass die Aktie steigt
das hat einen Grund lange genug hat rein
metallprobleme in Deutschland Stichwort
auch wenn man mal Richtung Europa
schauen auch das Thema Taxonomie ist
jetzt ein bisschen sehr differenziert
ging darum dass das eine Industrie ist
die Waffen produziert mit der man nichts
zu tun haben will aber es geht nicht
darum irgendwelche Angriffswaffen weil
man irgendwelche Länder erobern will
sondern weil man helfen will dass die
Ukraine verteidigen ganz konkret um den
äh Anstieg in der Kurve ausgestattet
nach der Nachricht dass Deutschland den
Leopard liefert ja ein Metall baut wie
Sie wissen den Leopard freuen Sie sich
über diese positive
Wirtschaftsentwicklung Frage genommen
ich freue mich über jede positive
Wirtschaftsentwicklung da habe ich keine
Scheuklappen und natürlich finde ich
auch wichtig dass sie dir solche
Unternehmen in Deutschland halten und
insofern Aktien würde ich mir jetzt
nicht kaufen wieder von Rheinland Teil
noch von woanders aber ich finde es ich
finde es richtig und nachvollziehbar
dass die jetzt dass sie eine gute
Zukunft prognostiziert das am Ende die
Aktienkäufer glauben ja genau das und
das hat natürlich etwas mit dem 100
Milliarden Paket zu tun das hat etwas
mit der Entscheidung Deutschlands zu tun
im Verbund mit den anderen sich so in
der Ukraine zu engagieren wieder klar
ist Regierung und das
spd-bundeskanzlers sein dass kleine
Bäcker und kleine Fleischereien
Metzgereien pleite gehen und rein Metall
und die deutsche Kriegswirtschaft boomt
wie nie zuvor nein also ich kann schon
gut nachvollziehen warum sie so
zugespitzt formulieren aber wir uns ist
auch überhaupt nicht egal ob ein Bäcker
oder ein Schlachter ob sie ihm gut oder
schlecht geht und wir engagieren uns da
auch vor Ort das tun alle Abgeordneten
in allen Wahlkreisen da bin ich fest von
überzeugt und die Hilfen die wir aus auf
den Weg gebracht haben die ja noch ein
bisschen höher sogar als in der
corona-pandemie sind aber es war einfach
erforderlich die werden ja die Länder
ausgebracht weil Frau Klöckner ja von
darauf hingewiesen hat wie schwierig das
manchmal ist die Anträge zu stellen wir
stellen das Geld zur Verfügung und über
die Länder wird das dann an diejenigen
weitergegeben sozusagen beantragen die
Kriterien jetzt zum Beispiel bei der
gaspreisbremse zusammen die Länder nicht
gemacht da wurde von der
gaspreiskommission die von der
Bundesregierung eingesetzt worden ist
wurden die Empfehlungen gar nicht
umgesetzt jetzt die Kriterien führen
dazu dass uns immer mehr Betriebe sagen
also unter diesen Kriterien werden wir
das nicht beanspruchen so und insofern
müssen wir auch Acht geben dass wir das
nicht nur auf die Länder eben schieben
nicht das so trotz es geht auch mal was
daneben und wenn es keine Blaupause gibt
aber man muss dann schon erwarten von
einer Regierung wenn sie sieht dass
etwas nicht fliegt also nicht
funktioniert dann muss man korrigieren
wir machen an der Stelle
runter oder dieses Thema sprechen aber
noch ganz kurz über eines dass uns in
diesen Stunden so besonders bewegt eine
Messerattacke eine neue Messerattacke in
einem Regionalexpress zwischen Hamburg
und Kiel
tote 16 Jahre und 19 Jahre sind diese
beiden Opfer ein Mädchen und ein junger
Mann auch Opfer der deutschen
Migrationspolitik Frau Klöckner
es kann nicht pauschal gar nicht
beantworten so sagen das sind Opfer der
deutschen Migrationspolitik müssen wir
erstmal die deutsche Migrationspolitik
definieren müssen definitiv ich weiß zu
wenig über diesen Fall aber ich scheue
mich nicht grundsätzlich über
Migrationspolitik zu reden sie wissen
ich habe schon sehr sehr frühzeitig auch
über das ein problematisches Frauenbild
ohne das jetzt in den Topf zu werfen
weil ich dazu nichts weiß deshalb will
ich das jetzt auch unterscheiden aber
sie Wissenschaft sehr frühzeitig und
auch ein Buch darüber geschrieben und
mir wurde dann Islamophobie und
Fremdenfeindlichkeit vorgeworfen weil
ich angefangen hat habe dass Menschen zu
uns kommen Männer zu uns kommen die
besser leben wollen was ich total
nachvollziehen kann aber ihr Frauenbild
von zu Hause mitbringen und eben nicht
die Spielregeln in Deutschland auch
akzeptieren ich habe es erlebt dass ich
in einer Einrichtung war wovon Frauen
oder wo aus Frauen hin kein Essen
entgegengenommen worden da würde ich
sagen okay dann seid ihr halt sagt die
Jungs und ich habe es auch erlebt dass
mir
wirklich strenggläubige die Hand nicht
geben wollen wenn die sagen die Klöckner
mag ich nicht ich mag die CDU nicht
alles in Ordnung aber wenn sie sagen
weil sie eine Frau sind da muss halt
nicht es geht nicht jetzt will ich noch
mal wir müssen differenziert vorgehen
aber auch die Debatten um Ehrenmord und
vieles andere auch das sind ja Punkt ich
würde auch nie ihren Mod nennen weil es
kein Mord aufgrund von Ehre geben kann
aber da müssen wir jetzt acht geben ich
finde schon dass auf beiden Seiten die
Reflexe nicht so schnell kommen wird von
der einen Seite das hat alles mit mit
ausländern zu tun ist genauso falsch wie
diejenigen die sagen das ist typisch
rassistisch und es Nazi wäre darüber
reden will so und wir müssen wieder in
der Mitte der Gesellschaft auch über
Probleme reden ja in der Tat und genau
das tun wir zum Abschluss dieser Sendung
vor Hagedorn ein Mann der 2014 zu uns
gekommen ist ein Staatenloser
Palästinenser der eine relativ lange
Strafakte schon hat der gerade im Knast
war ein paar Tage raus ist der sticht
brutal und offenbar wahllos zu wir
erleben eine starke Zunahme dieser oder
ähnlicher Messerattacken in Deutschland
seit geraumer Zeit und viele würden an
der Stelle sagen naja wenn der 24 nicht
vermutlich illegal zu uns gekommen wäre
dann wäre diese Tat nicht passiert also
ich tue mich schwer genau wie Julia
knöckner weil ich zu wenig von dem Fall
weiß also das ist in Schleswig-Holstein
passiert ich komme aus
Schleswig-Holstein das ist eine
Zugstrecke die ich auch selbst schon
viele Male gefahren bin das Alter der
beiden getöteten Opfer lässt darauf
schließen es ist ja auch sehr
wahrscheinlich das ist möglicherweise
SchülerInnen eine Schülerin und Schüler
war auch meine eigenen Enkelkinder
benutzen in Zukunft so Schule zu kommen
also das macht mich erstmal total
fassungslos und betroffen und ähm und
ich finde es einfach zu schnell wenn wir
jetzt aus diesem Moment der
Betroffenheit mit den Angehörigen ohne
wirklich richtig Kenntnisse zu haben was
da genau vorgefallen ist schon versuchen
daraus Schlüssel zu ziehen ich kenne die
Innenministerin von Schleswig-Holstein
sehr gut und sehr lange und ich schätze
sie sehr und ich selbst sie hat sich ja
bisher erst sehr zurückhaltend und ich
meine wenn jemand etwas weiß dann ist es
als erstes nachher die Innenministerin
und dann wird sie die Öffentlichkeit
auch darüber informieren aber zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt finde ich solche
Fragen schwierig sie werden nur
irgendwann aus dem Zustand der
Betroffenheit auch wieder rausfinden
müssen und in den Zustand Informiertheit
über den Zustand in den Zustand des
Handels kommen müssen danken Ihnen
hierbei Bild für ihre Worte und ihre
Diskussion und sind nächste Woche zurück
hier bei Bild die richtigen Fragen
[Musik]
danke